speaking of helping us out we're going
to begin this hour with our series
protecting the planet ahead of Earth day
which is on Saturday and of course
innovators are searching for solutions
to our climate crisis and they need all
the help that they can get well they are
in luck because they have a new champion
who made his name and his fortune years
ago in Silicon Valley Alexis o'hanian he
is the co-founder of Reddit and he is a
driving force behind a foundation that
is funding young entrepreneurs working
to meet the challenges of a warming
Planet senior National and environmental
correspondent Ben Tracy sat down with
the Titan of tech and also met some of
the impressive young people who may be
our best hope I say they are our best
hope for the future
we live in a big diverse and beautiful
world and that makes me even more
passionate to save it Maya pen gave her
first Ted Talk when she was just 11. she
started her own sustainable fashion line
at age eight and earlier this year was
featured in Vogue for her climate
activism alongside singer Billy eilish
so your resume is basically three pages
long at the age of 22. congratulations
thank you now let me find the things I
was just telling you about and now at 23
she's finishing work on an animated
short film about bees and the loss of
their habitat
it's an environmental action adventure
and I really want to normalize topics
like sustainability normalized topics
like climate and environment Viola Davis
is an executive producer and Whoopi
Goldberg is voicing one of the
characters it was extremely extremely
surreal hearing words I wrote come out
of her mouth it's got to feel good
Alexis Ohanian selected Penn as one of
the first recipients of his 100 000
grants for climate and environmental
entrepreneurs what does it mean to you
to have somebody say I believe in what
you're doing and here's a hundred
thousand dollars to do it it means the
world being a woman being a black woman
being so young did you feel like you
were often dismissed by people because
of those things I feel like I've
definitely been like dismissed or gate
kept out of a lot of spaces because of
those factors the most inspiring folks
are the individuals who are doing the
work they are just compelling as hell
Ohanian was also an overachiever
co-founding the social media Network
read it when he was 22. he says if he
had a do-over he would have done
something else yeah climate Tech is the
kind of company I would start today the
greatest existential threat we have is
the threat to climate in many ways if we
don't solve that problem nothing else is
going to matter in 100 years this was an
experiment that started out as a kind of
crazy idea maybe a year ago these are
the first grant recipients of Ohanian
776 Foundation which intends to give out
20 million dollars to fund climate
Solutions we just want to see the best
ideas get funding even if you haven't
totally figured out and it's just in its
research project stage great here's a
hundred thousand dollars this has to be
one of the best parts of having a lot of
money it's true it's true 20 young
people from all corners of the world are
using his first round of funding to
attempt everything from removing Planet
warming carbon emissions from the air
increasing the spread of wildfires
one is building fully robotic Micro Labs
for biotech research and development
while another is reusing waste created
by recycling aluminum we are closing the
loop on aluminum recycling Ross dam
reifschider was just 20 when he started
his california-based company hydrova it
turns the waste byproduct of aluminum
recycling called dross so this is dross
right here some nice chunks of it into a
raw material for making cement that
could help keep one million tons of
dross out of landfills every year
using it to make cement lowers the
carbon footprint of an industry which
accounts for nearly eight percent of all
planet warming emissions what makes a 20
year old interested in the waste
byproduct of aluminum I grew up in
California and I've witnessed the
effects of climate change firsthand I
always knew that I wanted to dedicate my
career towards climate change and
bettering the environment man
hydrova has proven their technology
works but Ohanian says he knows that
many of the efforts he funds will fail I
tell these fellows I just need one y'all
to do something amazing and I will be
bragging about that for the rest of my
years to my daughter and be like hey
remember Papa first one to believe in
that thing that saved our planet he's
talking about his five-year-old daughter
Olympia who he shares with his wife and
tennis star Serena Williams I want
people to come up to Olympia talking
about how cool her dad is just as much
as people come up to her and say how
cool her mom is
look I don't think I'm going to win but
I'm going to put up a hell of a fight
and it may just also be a win for the
planet at the end of the day we're just
trying to solve one problem which is
keep this Earth habitable for a very
long time and that's what I want to
spend the rest of my life doing climate
fellows thank you for taking a bet on us
for CBS mornings I'm Ben Tracy in Austin
cool Alexis I didn't realize he was 22
when he started Reddit so he knows
something about being a 20-something
person with big ideas and Big Dreams and
wanting to change I like how he says you
don't even have to have it all figured
out yeah just an idea research phase
great here's 100 Grand magic words on
the bottom coming up and that it's not
always going to work but I'm going to
support you and try to help you get
there you know what I love about that
shot at the table is the diversity yeah
remember too I noticed that you have the
race races from all over the world
genders and different backgrounds some
of the brightest Minds in the world
everybody gets a seat at the table yes
it helped change the world all we got to
do is solve that small problem keeping
the Earth habitable yeah well I thought
he raised a good point if we don't have
the planet we have nothing yeah so let's
get that right it's a real life Captain
Planet right there that's right